welcome to this video playing aqaba in
the house and let's go for this line
again oh now g5 sm is an uncommon move
mostly because it's not so clear what
what is what the nights are doing we
night every I play age 6 he's got no
good way to develop his pieces now yeah
okay this is this kind of setup but this
isn't isn't so great okay um see 5 or
not yeah why not no reason not to
just looks like a quite a quite solid
position so 95 yeah more than one good
good setup here
the bishop on age seven is quite a good
piece maybe I'm ad on a good day I I can
get a piece to d3 mmm this is weird what
is this nice post him yeah it looks like
he's really intended to to sacrifice on
e6 which seems some quite quite unlike
it unlikely to work what are you doing
now
okay so i could it could take the Queen
and take the rope here Orca take the
piece hmm okay let's do that
it's a it's a look at the moment yeah no
but check so let's let's do a body count
here I'm piece up right yeah it's just a
piece and the sea three ponies like
resign beyond salvation you are quite a
strange game yeah before it's just just
a strange move giving me a good post in
the center and weakening although
complete position is just weakened again
the comp immediately goes to a rather
big black edge it wants to take with the
bishop though okay Bishop d3 but this is
no problem okay let that again this just
once winds from black 92 no wait minus 4
no way to save the peace now yeah like
just wins a PCM 95 is really not not a
good move against the Bronstein las 11
reason is also i didn't i didn't play
that at one business acumen get me to
this position there is also the movie 5
i believe okay then he has Bishop c4 I'm
sorry not at this point yeah but ok
Bishop that five was just simple and
good alright thanks for watching